i could i can cut women's hair
so that's like a good thing but i did i
used to do just bangs and things once in
a while you know
fringes and and uh every once in a while
when they were younger you know tidy it
up a little bit whatever i did you know
make
everyone smile cut they and they got a
kick out of it when i tried to do my son
it was it was really a disaster because
i
i'm not of good he had some um
we would watch um uh you know watch tv
in the morning like sesame street or
this or that or the other thing
and i can't remember exactly what we
were watching but there was a
there was some years ago he's like in
his 30s now
but there was a boy band or something or
something was going on
there was a guy who had a haircut that
he liked and i said oh yeah i probably
could do that and i can't remember he
must have been about
seven years old oh my god did you mess
it up i messed it up
so bad it was like you know just then
and
and the reaction was
crazy because he wouldn't get his hair
cut then
and uh you know he look just wouldn't he
no
he wouldn't let anybody cut his hair oh
you started absolutely happened
was that i created this like because of
this
you know doing this not not very good
job
i wound up with a a nine-year-old
right who nine your jake
whose hair was like
it was like it was definitely like you
know uh it was definitely
like yeah it was just like just totally
uh off the charts uh wouldn't get it cut
and um and it was fun it was kind of
like
and the girls got a kick out of it
because um
they were good at very good looking kid
and every once in a while
they would go you know somebody would
invariably say
oh god you've got three great daughters
you know what i mean
and they get the kick out of it you know
jake would go
you know he leaned in that's a lot of
that's a great comedy right there just
in the making he leaned in
so i mean i actually heard that it was
you went to beauty school before you're
an actor
yeah yeah is it was it your sister she
under salon or something
my sister angie was the she was 16 years
older than
two is the oldest in the fam i had two
sisters two older sisters
that's quite a bit older yeah yeah and
when i graduated
she had a beauty parlor so she said why
don't you come to work for me and i was
like
18 i think she said she sent me to
school
to do it i said i don't know if i you
know can i
is this like something that's in my
wheelhouse you know yeah
do this so we spent all summer she
got me ready to go to and she paid my
way and then
i got wow and i got my license and i
and i and i worked in her salon and then
she abused me for like
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going